Minnesota Timberwolves beat Ryder for
the Minneapolis star-tribune here on the
show how you doing Chris appreciate you
taking the time here amidst all the
drama
walk me through yesterday you're there
with the with the rest of the beat
that's covering the Timberwolves and
then all of a sudden what filters in
that Jimmy Butler's in the gym yeah so
here's so here's what happened we we
kind of knew that that Butler might be a
practice so but they do not allow the
media into the practice to watch it so
you know nobody really had any idea what
was what was happening they tell you to
go at a certain time show up at a
certain time for media availability the
practice ended a half-hour early
yesterday now we don't know if that was
because of what Jimmy Butler did or not
that's very unusual that practice ended
a half-hour early and so they let us in
we talked to Thibodeaux for a few
minutes he doesn't mention anything
about Butler a couple of players come
Anthony Tolliver and Jeff Teague and
they're asked about Butler and their
comments don't really you know make you
think that anything weird that happens
or anything out of the ordinary Jeff
Teague who is one of the most I think
I'm shakable guys in the NBA just kind
of said yeah we had a good practice
Jimmy was around it means my friends you
know he brings a lot of good energy to
the team comments to kind of look
hilarious and Himes in hindsight based
on what happened yesterday but really
you would have you wouldn't have had any
idea that anything out of the ordinary
it happened yesterday if you had shown
up for media availability after practice
so how does one insert oneself into a
lineup of third stringers Chris what did
you hear how did that seriously like I
want to know the actual how does one do
that in a practice that I'm not sure how
that all went down
people around the team are being very
quiet right now and it's it's kind of
hard to get anybody to talk about this
but it was it was quite remarkable the
legend of this practice and it's it's
something that is probably going to grow
throughout time but that's that's kind
of what happened he challenged cat he
challenged Wiggins he challenged the
front office he's
what he said he tried to know I guess
walk it back a little bit later in his
ESPN interview but but all that stuff
happened yesterday and it's quite
remarkable it basically laid there all
the issues that have been going on with
this team that have been bubbling under
the surface since late last season the
tension with Wiggins in town especially
well what is attention about he doesn't
think they've got it they don't have the
stomach the heart or they don't care
they don't exactly yeah I think in some
ways Jimmy Butler is kind of an
extension of Tom Thibodeau on the court
he's very hard driving very demanding
very competitive and I think that's why
he and Thibodeau have gotten along for
so well or so well throughout most of
Butler's time here in the NBA and I
think he looked at towns and Wiggins and
you know he seems to guys that he
doesn't think work as hard as he does
that was the mantra that he kept
repeating late last season it's
something that he said last night and
his interview these guys have all the
talent in the world but they don't work
as hard as me and I think that's the
main issue and that's the main reason
why he wants out of Minnesota is because
he doesn't think he can win with those
guys now the ironic thing is you look at
his list of teams that he wants to go to
the Nets the Knicks and to a lesser
extent the Clippers and you say well
those teams don't seem to be in a great
position to win right away so what's
this all about so in a lot of ways he's
sending mixed messages with with some of
his comments some of his action well
Chris Pine Minneapolis star-tribune here
the mixed message as well is that he's
saying the issue isn't money it's the
players that are on the court and then
why is he yelling at Scott Laden because
those are the players that Scott Laden
is telling Glen Taylor is the nucleus of
this team is that is that is that why
he's barking at the general manager here
in price I think I think so it was a
weird comment because I don't think the
Timberwolves would dispute that they
need Jimmy Butler to win that was
allegedly what he said that you bleeping
need me to win and I don't think the
Timberwolves are disputing that I think
that's why he's still on the roster and
this still hasn't been a trade made
because I think Thibodeau is still
holding out a glimmer of hope that
Butler is going to be on this roster and
there's they can try to make the play
with him there I don't think they
dispute that but it's you know what's
this all about I think a lot of it is
money at the end of the day I think that
their Butler's and his camper mad that
the Timberwolves did not throw out a
deal as they could have under the CBA
and given him a new max deal this summer
they only offered him a four-year 110
million dollar extension they had
renegotiated him deal this summer it
would have necessitated a lot of salary
cap maneuvering that the Wolves were not
ready to undertake yeah but if he
doesn't think the guys around him are
our winning players or have the winning
attitude required to take on the
Warriors well because obviously that's
that's that's essentially what we're
talking about here essentially in that
conference then why does he want to be
maxed out there again okay situation you
know we don't really know you know how
much does money talk in a situation like
this when we are staring at a and a
paycheck for you know 30 or 40 million
dollars more that any team can offer you
how much does that really talk and how
much are you able to tolerate you know
having a Andrew Wiggins and karl-anthony
towns on your team if it means signing
for 30 to 40 extra million dollars it's
a lot of money and I don't know that
there's an easy answer to that question
he says it's not about the money but you
know from from what I've gleaned that it
is a little bit about the money but I
think we're just beginning to get to the
confusing part to Chris Hein as well as
I should throw out to that Rachel in her
interview with Jimmy Butler did say one
point recounting the end of last season
how he came back and talked about losing
in the first round sirs against the
number one seed Houston she interrupted
her and said that's a really good team
too by the way is what he said I mean
why not go there too so a couple things
here now did has the owner
ordered him traded or not and if he did
tell Board of Governors
members that he's gonna get out of there
why hasn't he been traded Glen Taylor
has demanded are not demanded but has
said that he wants Butler he has told
Thibodeau a lady wants Butler traded so
that is the working mandate for this
organization right now now he has left
it up to Thibodeau and lady to do that
Taylor is not really doing the
day-to-day a negotiating of a deal so
the guiding mantra is that Taylor wants
Butler dealt but Thibodeau and laden are
the West handling those negotiations and
so the trades involving superstars can
sometimes take a while Kyrie Irving took
weeks to get dealt it look what happened
with kaleidos this offseason so Taylor
wants it dealt but it's taking time
because I think in part said oh my hope
Butler comes back but secondly these
trades take a while and they have to
create leverage in a market that is not
a very favorable market for them right
now so I think you're seeing that kind
of conflict come to a front here yes the
owner wants and gone but it's taking
time to get a deal that they want well
to use the phrase from Star Trek to
Wrath of Khan Chris I don't usually
quote that but time is a luxury they do
not have to be honest with you here and
the seasons right around the corner and
Jimmy Butler is making things on
comfortable to say the least and my
question is is how does karl-anthony
towns kick that ball out that to me out
of everything made me sit there and
think the Timberwolves truly have a
problem even if Butler goes how does
karl-anthony towns not take that ball
and just throw it at him you know I
don't know and I think that is what
Butler is saying it's it's part of why
he doesn't think he can coexist with
these guys because they just don't have
the same fire the same drives that he
does and that has shown up at practice
before I heard that you know a lot of
some people within the Wolves
organization yesterday just kind of
viewed what happened and another day in
the life of having Jimmy Butler on your
team that it wasn't really
that out of the ordinary if you can
believe that it seems crazy to us
outside but there were someone's an
organization that we're like well it's
just Jimmy being Jimmy in a sense well I
you know I don't know if this is a
proper analogy Chris I mean certainly
definitely not in terms of personnel
that have never met Jimmy Butler one of
the reasons why the Cowboys told Dez
Bryant we're done here is because a lot
of members of the coaching staff thought
that dak did not need him chirping in
his ear anymore he needed to have a more
confident group around him to build that
up his Jimmy Butler stunting
karl-anthony towns growth just by being
there do you think he could absolutely
and they have so much money tied up now
in towns and Wiggins you know I think
about 340 million between those two guys
that you don't need anybody around
stunting their growth now what I think
might be happening is I think in some
ways Thibodeau might look at this as a
positive in some ways that having Butler
around having somebody to really get at
these guys might inspire might inspire
them to greater heights now you could
debate the merits of that but I think
that that's definitely in play here but
I don't know that that's necessarily the
best thing for the long-term health of
the franchise all right two more
questions for you did the Timberwolves
know ESPN was coming I think they were a
little surprised by that from what I've
gathered that that was not obviously not
arranged through the team so there was a
bit of Marcus Reese in there on Butler
in his camps part to have ESPN there is
that his rec room did they go to his
house what was that spot I'm not sure
where that where that was locate it's
not a local Dave & Buster's or something
like that's very nice rec room I gotta
be honest first but yeah I don't know if
did the Timberwolves were making Jimmy
available for a one-on-one sit-down
Chris I'll be honest with you because it
certainly cuz that's my last question
for you today they cancel practice
practice canceled what what now what's
happening now what's the next step of
crystal ballin essentially the next step
is I'm going to hop in a car and drive
to Milwaukee for their preseason
game on Friday night and we're gonna see
what happens in Milwaukee tomorrow I
think you know the next 24 hours could
be interesting we'll see if canceling
practice precipitates a move of some
time if they're trying to buy time to
get a deal done I think that's that
could be in the cards but I'm not 100%
certain of that we'll see the next the
next 24 hours the next week is going to
be fascinating lit as the kids say any
chance Butler plays Friday night you
think I think there's a chance he said
he would he suddenly has P an interview
that he would practice on Thursday so I
think there's a chance that he could
play on Friday who do they play against
Milwaukee okay so I see what you're
saying okay so any chance that he Butler
inserts himself into the bench of the
Milwaukee Bucks during that game Kris I
don't know anything out unbelievable the
whole thing's unbelievable by the way I
really always appreciate quality
journalism and quality writing you
should check out Chris's article on Star
Tribune calm the lead paragraph Jimmy
Butler sure knows how to make an
entrance even if he desperately wants to
make an exit well done Chris Han thank
you thanks for calling we appreciate
that appreciate you calling the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience